Let me show you what I did. I removed this line. I added a parameter, then I
used the parameter here. And am I done here? not quite. I still have to
document the parameter. Pat yourself on the back if you did that. Now, onto the
main method. Here, I want to read the input. So, I declare a scanner and I use
it to read the added redness over here, I'd pass that value through the redden
method. Now, there's a couple of things that I soon need to do. First off, the
prompt, here it is, notice print not print on and the extra space. And finally,
up here. I need the import statement. Now, we're ready to go. When running the
program, I'm prompted for the added redness. I'm going to go and crank it way
up here. And, woah, that's pretty red. Now, the benefit of having the input
provided by the user, is I can now experiment with other values, I simply run
the program again. And just to see if it works, I'll supply a negative number.
And as you can see, now the image got a little bluer, greener, whatever, less
red. Now, you know how to read user input in Java.